This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字的2%。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但你可以和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须去这么做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of your 20s. Have you ever looked at your life or maybe the life of other people around you and thought, is it always going to be this busy? Is it always going to be this chaotic? Do we ever get a brick? Or is it just this constant drum in the back of your head
后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析你二十岁的心理。你有没有审视过自己的生活，或者可能审视过身边其他人的生活，然后想：生活会一直这么忙碌吗？生活会一直这么混乱吗？我们能休息一下吗？还是说，这只是你脑海深处的某种持续不断的鼓点
of drama, of overwhelm, of things to do? You're always on the go. You're always reacting. Always just a little bit on. Maybe, just maybe, there is also a part of you that thrives on it, that feels most alive, shall we say, when the stakes are really, really high, when the deadline is tomorrow, when the relationship is on the brink. I know I've definitely had those moments. What we're talking about today is chaos, the nature of chaos, the kind that isn't accidental, but sometimes almost invited, the kind that makes you wonder, am I addicted to this? Am I the problem? Is the reason all my friendships have failed? The jobs didn't work out. I feel behind. I. I feel I feel on edge, is that maybe my tolerance for chaos and the fact that I always feel like
充满了戏剧性、压倒性的情绪和要做的事情？你总是步履匆匆。你总是在做出反应。总是处于紧绷状态。也许，仅仅也许，你的内心深处也有一部分人以此为生，可以说，当风险非常非常高、截止日期就是明天、关系濒临破裂时，你会觉得自己最有活力。我知道我肯定有过那些时刻。我们今天要讨论的是混乱，混乱的本质，那种并非偶然发生，有时甚至几乎是自找的混乱，那种让你怀疑的混乱：我是对这个上瘾了吗？我是那个问题所在吗？难道这就是我所有友谊都破裂的原因吗？工作没有成功。我感觉自己落后了。我。我觉得我感到局促不安，也许是因为我对混乱的忍耐力，以及我总是觉得自己
I need to crash out or explode my life for it to be entertaining. Now, I don't mean when I say this that we are all out here actively trying to sabotage our lives and cause drama. Most of us are, I think, consciously striving for peace and stability. But if we're honest, sometimes unconsciously, we do our best in the state. urgency, that hum of drama, that staticness feels normal, even exhilarating. How do we break that habit? How do we break the curse of feeling addicted to chaos and feel comfortable in stillness and comfortable in peace? This is something that I've been thinking about a lot, especially after
需要崩溃或者把生活搞得一团糟才能让它变得有趣。现在，当我说这话时，并不是指我们都在这里积极地试图破坏我们的生活并制造戏剧性。我想，我们大多数人都曾在有意识地争取平静和稳定。但如果我们诚实地说，有时我们在无意识中，确实在那种状态下表现得最好。那种紧迫感，那种戏剧性的嗡嗡声，那种静电般的氛围让人感觉正常，甚至令人振奋。我们如何打破这种习惯？我们如何打破对混乱上瘾的感觉的诅咒，并在宁静中感到舒适，在和平中感到舒适？这是我一直在思考的一个问题，特别是在
receiving a few messages from you all who basically shared the same sentiment. How can I tell if I'm the problem, how can I break out of this pattern? So today we are diving headfirst into the question, are we addicted to chaos? We are going to investigate why we might inadvertently be drawn to situations that are fraught with tension and that have a sense of urgency. We're going to look at how this plays out in our relationships, why we may crave excitement and anxiety over safety in our romantic relationships, our personal lives, our careers, and we're going to get into the often hidden deeper reasons why we might cling to this tumultuous state or might unconsciously sabotage our efforts for peace. And crucially, what do we do about it? What are the small mental shifts
收到你们的一些信息之后，你们基本上都表达了同样的看法。我怎么知道我是不是那个问题所在，我该如何打破这个模式？所以今天我们一头扎进这个问题：我们对混乱上瘾了吗？我们要调查为什么我们可能会无意中被充满紧张感和紧迫感的情况所吸引。我们将探讨这如何在我们的关系中发挥作用，为什么在浪漫关系、个人生活和职业生涯中，我们可能会对兴奋和焦虑的渴望胜过安全感，并且我们将深入探讨那些往往隐藏在背后的更深层次的原因，即为什么我们可能会紧抓这种动荡的状态不放，或者可能会在无意识中破坏我们为和平所做出的努力。最重要的是，我们该怎么办？有哪些微小的心理转变
that we need to take to embrace stillness, to embrace the discomfort of standing still, without feeling like our lives aren't moving in the correct direction and so much more. So without further ado, let's explore whether deep down we are addicted to chaos and what to do about it. Okay, let's cut straight to the chase. Why does chaos, or rather the resolution of chaos, sometimes feel so freaking good? What's really happening here is a bit of a neurochemical roller coaster that in subtle ways makes us addicted to urgency, not because of how good it feels in the moment, but because of how good
我们需要采取这些措施来拥抱静止，拥抱静止不动的不适感，而不会觉得我们的生活没有朝着正确的方向发展，等等。闲话少说，让我们来探讨一下，在内心深处，我们是否对混乱上瘾了，以及该如何应对。好了，我们开门见山吧。为什么混乱，或者更确切地说，混乱的解决，有时感觉如此美妙？这里真正发生的事情是一场神经化学过山车，它以微妙的方式让我们对紧迫感上瘾，不是因为它在当下感觉有多好，而是因为之后我们感觉有多好
we feel afterwards. When you're facing a crisis, such as a looming deadline or relationship argument or an unexpected problem, your body kicks into high gear. This is your sympathetic nervous system taking over initiating the very famous fight or flight response. As a response to that, your brain is going to release adrenaline. It's going to release cortisol, the primary stress hormones, your heart rate goes up, your senses sharpened, you have this burst of energy. This is obviously used as a primal survival mechanism. It's meant to be designed. Well, it is designed to help us quickly react to danger. But here's the kicker. When you resolve that crisis when you escape the danger, when you survive, when you meet the deadline, when you clear your inbox,
当我们面对危机时，比如迫在眉睫的截止日期、关系争吵或意想不到的问题，你的身体就会进入高负荷运转状态。这是你的交感神经系统接管并引发著名的“战斗或逃跑”反应。作为对该反应的回报，你的大脑会释放肾上腺素。它会释放皮质醇，这是主要的应激激素，你的心率上升，你的感官变得敏锐，你会有这种爆发性的能量。这显然被用作原始的生存机制。它旨在被设计出来。嗯，它的设计初衷就是为了帮助我们对危险做出快速反应。但关键在这里。当你解决危机时，当你逃离危险时，当你生存下来时，当你赶上截止日期时，当你清理收件箱时，
there's a drop in those stress hormones. And often, as a response, your brain releases dopamine, it releases DMT and that feeling of relief is what we're actually after is what we actually crave. Your brain being the incredibly efficient learning machine that it is actually starts to associate this crisis resolution dopamine hit cycle with reward rather than with the stress and the anxiety and the panic that came before. So the chaos itself is uncomfortable, but the payoff of getting through it, is so rewarding that that's actually the thing we start to chase. If it feels counterintuitive, it really is. It's not just that we want stress, we get used to the reward.
这些应激激素会有所下降。通常，作为回应，你的大脑会释放多巴胺，释放DMT，而这种如释重负的感觉正是我们真正追求的，也是我们真正渴望的。你的大脑作为一个极其高效的学习机器，实际上开始将“危机解决-多巴胺打击”循环与奖励联系起来，而不是与之前随之而来的压力、焦虑和恐慌联系起来。所以混乱本身是不舒服的，但熬过它的回报是如此之高，以至于这实际上成了我们开始追逐的东西。如果这感觉违反直觉，那它确实如此。我们不仅想要压力，我们还习惯了这种奖励。
The same way that people love scary movies, love endurance sports, all those kinds of things. They reason they love them is because of the secondary emotion and the secondary reaction that comes with living through them. This can be explained by principles of operant conditioning, where a behavior, so engaging with or creating chaos is reinforced by a positive outcome, the dopamine rush of resolution, so that we continue to engage in it to get the reward. Of course, in this situation, some of the wires have kind of been crossed, but regardless, this underlying dopinogenic principle is why this practice and these patterns of behavior do feel so addictive. Beyond the pure neurochemistry,
就像人们喜欢恐怖电影、喜欢耐力运动以及所有这些类型的东西一样。他们喜欢它们的原因是因为经历它们所带来的次要情绪和次要反应。这可以用操作性条件反射的原理来解释，在这种原理中，一种行为（即参与或制造混乱）会通过积极的结果（解决问题带来的多巴胺激增）得到强化，从而我们继续参与其中以获得奖励。当然，在这种情况下，某些神经回路有点错位了，但无论如何，这种潜在的多巴胺能原理正是这种做法和行为模式让人感到如此上瘾的原因。除了纯粹的神经化学，
there is also, of course, a psychological draw to novelty and intensity. Our brains are wired, hard wire to pay attention to new, surprising, intense stimuli. In fact, one of my favorite studies ever conducted actually found that having more novel and new experiences actually creates the illusion of more time in our days and therefore our lives. So our brain is really looking for that newness. Calm, consistent, predictable routines, whilst they're healthy, They don't necessarily provide the same kind of immediate sensory and emotional stimulation or sense of expansiveness compared to this constant flux and unpredictability. And this is the deeper problem is that we start to equate chaos to this sense of being alive and truly experiencing things.
当然，心理上也会受到新鲜感和强烈刺激的吸引。我们的大脑生来就倾向于关注新的、令人惊讶的、强烈的刺激。事实上，我最喜欢的一项研究发现，拥有更多新奇的体验实际上会在我们的日常生活中甚至生活中产生一种时间更多的错觉。所以我们的大脑真的在寻找这种新鲜感。平静、一致、可预测的常规虽然很健康，但与这种不断的变化和不可预测性相比，它们不一定会提供同等程度的即时感官和情感刺激或广阔感。这是一个更深层次的问题，即我们开始将混乱等同于这种充满活力和真正体验事物的感受。
It's the opposite of boredom. And for many of us, especially in our 20s, where we are constantly seeking out new experiences, we are pushing boundaries. we don't want to miss out on anything critical and fun and exciting. Avoiding boredom, avoiding plainness can be a powerful motivator. Research on sensation-seeking, which is this trait where we really seek out newness and novelty, shows that individuals with higher needs for varied, novel, and complex sensations might actually unconsciously gravitate towards more chaotic and stimulating environments. So in these studies, they were the ones who ran towards the fire, essentially.
这是无聊的反面。对于我们许多人来说，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，我们不断寻求新的体验，突破界限。我们不想错过任何关键、有趣和令人兴奋的事情。避免无聊，避免平淡可以成为强大的动力。对寻求刺激的研究（这是一种我们真正寻求新鲜感和新奇感的特质）表明，对各种新奇和复杂感觉有更高需求的个人实际上可能会无意识地倾向于更混乱和更具刺激性的环境。所以在这些研究中，他们基本上就是那些冲向火海的人。
they were the ones who got involved in the drama. And on this point of novelty and intensity, it is also worth touching on ADHD. For individuals with ADHD, there is a known difference in how your brain processes and regulates dopamine. And also, it's counterpart noraphynephrine, which you need dopamine in order to release and for your brain to understand. The brains of people with ADHD have an imbalance of dopamine. Specifically, notably, normally lower levels of dopamine in certain brain regions, but also there is research that's beginning to support that they also have fewer dopamine receptors and more of this protein that actually cleans up dopamine on the synapse,
他们是那些卷入戏剧性事件中的人。关于新鲜感和强烈刺激这一点，也值得谈谈ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）。对于患有ADHD的个人来说，你的大脑处理和调节多巴胺的方式存在已知的差异。还有它的对应物去甲肾上腺素，你需要多巴胺才能释放它并让你的大脑理解它。ADHD患者的大脑有多巴胺失衡。具体来说，显着的是，某些大脑区域的多巴胺水平通常较低，但也有研究开始支持，他们还拥有更少的多巴胺受体和更多的这种实际上在突触上清除多巴胺的蛋白质，
meaning that dopamine messages will remain available on your brain for less time. So the happiness fades quicker. All of this basically means that they can really struggle with maintaining motivation, because dopamine is not just the happy chemical, it is responsible for motivation. It's responsible for feeling aligned with something, wanting to do something. It also means that their threshold for the positive feelings is a lot higher. So they have to experience more to get to a point of enjoyment or exhilaration compared to someone who doesn't have this a regulation.
这意味着多巴胺信息在你的大脑中保留的时间会缩短。所以快乐消逝得更快。所有这些基本上意味着他们在保持动机方面可能会真正挣扎，因为多巴胺不仅仅是快乐化学物质，它还负责动机。它负责让人感觉与某事保持一致，想要做某事。这也意味着他们对积极感觉的阈值要高得多。因此，与没有这种失调的人相比，他们必须经历更多的事情才能达到享受或兴奋的状态。
So this can lead to the drive for novelty and high stimulation as the brain seeks to achieve optimal arousal and a consistent flow of dopamine because of how the system may not be working. So if you have ADHD, for those of you with ADHD, constant demands, shifting priorities, the rush of last minute deadlines, that actually can feel pretty safe for you. That actually can feel quite normal. It can make you feel focused. It can make you feel engaged, even productive in a way that calmer, more predictable environments don't. And it's not that ADHD causes an addiction to chaos. It's that the underlying
因此，这会导致对新鲜感和高度刺激的驱动，因为大脑试图实现最佳唤醒和持续的多巴胺流动，这是由于系统可能无法正常工作。因此，如果你患有ADHD，对于你们这些患有ADHD的人来说，不断的要求、不断变化的工作重点、最后一刻截止日期的冲刺，实际上会让你觉得相当安全。这实际上可以让人感觉很正常。它能让你感到专注。它能让你感到投入，甚至以一种更平静、更可预测的环境所没有的方式感到高效。这并不是说ADHD会导致对混乱的上瘾。而是潜在的
neurological differences can make chaotic environments feel more engaging or even feel more comfortable, feel more right for some individuals, making it harder for them to step away from this intensity. So it's very important to understand this distinction between our addiction to chaos as a learned habit versus as a symptom of a brain that is wired just a little bit differently. However, for those addicted to chaos as a learned habit, many perceive there to be positive side effects of chaos, and that acts as the primary hook for this pattern. People who thrive in these environments, they often are incredibly effective in a crisis. They think quickly on their feet.
神经学上的差异会使混乱的环境对某些人来说更具吸引力，甚至更舒适、更正确，从而使他们更难摆脱这种强度。因此，非常重要的一点是，我们要区分我们将对混乱的上瘾视为一种习得的习惯，还是将其视为大脑布线略有不同的症状。然而，对于那些将对混乱上瘾视为习得习惯的人来说，许多人认为混乱有积极的副作用，这成为了这种模式的主要诱惑。在这些环境中茁壮成长的人，在危机中往往表现得极其高效。他们思维敏捷。
They can problem solve under immense pressure. they get things done when others might freeze. So it does feel like an asset. You do feel quite competent. You can go where no one else can go. You can do things that other people might not be able to do. And so in a period where we're forming our identity and our self-concept, the fact that we are good at doing this at putting out fires can feel quite validating and powerful. There's a certain thrill in being praised for this last-minute performance or for constantly proving people that you can overcome a challenge. Let's also not forget a crucial element to this, which is perceived control. Humans want to be in control. We want to feel like we
他们能够在巨大的压力下解决问题。当其他人可能会惊慌失措时，他们能把事情办妥。所以这确实感觉像是一种资产。你会觉得自己很有能力。你可以去别人去不了的地方。你可以做别人可能做不到的事情。因此，在塑造我们的自我认同和自我概念的时期，我们擅长做这件事——扑灭大火——的事实会让人感到非常具有肯定性和力量感。因为这种最后一刻的表现或不断向人们证明你可以克服挑战而受到称赞，本身就是一种刺激。让我们也不要忘记这其中的一个关键要素，那就是感知控制。人类想要掌控一切。我们希望觉得我们
matter. We want to feel like we can create change. We can do things. We can manage our environment that we have a say. Whilst chaos might seem like the opposite of control, sometimes by creating it artificially or deliberately, we reclaim a sense of agency because we create just enough chaos that we can feel in charge. This can be particularly appealing if you feel like you lack control in other areas of your life. So if your career progression is slow or major life decisions feel out of your hands, then the manageable chaos of a relationship or of going out all the time or of crashing out on the weekends or doing like insane stuff can almost feel productive. It can feel exhilarating. It can feel like you have something to do. The problems emerge when controlled care.
很重要。我们希望觉得我们可以创造改变。我们可以做事。我们可以管理我们的环境，我们可以拥有发言权。虽然混乱可能看起来与控制相反，但有时通过人工或故意制造混乱，我们重新获得了代理感，因为我们制造了刚好足够的混乱，让我们觉得自己掌控了一切。如果你觉得自己对生活其他领域的控制力不足，这尤其具有吸引力。因此，如果你的职业发展缓慢，或者生活中的重大决定感觉不受你控制，那么一段关系的易控混乱，或者经常出去玩，或者在周末崩溃，或者做一些疯狂的事情，几乎会让人觉得很有成效。它会让人感到振奋。它会让人觉得你有些事情可做。当受控的混。
chaos becomes uncontrolled, unmanageable, and maladaptive. Hopefully I've made this clear that this isn't about some grand, conscious plan to live in constant turmoil and we like throwing things up in the air and seeing where they land. It's actually our brain's quest for reward. It's our brain's quest for stimulation. It's our brain's quest for competence, self-efficacy, to feel like we can manage the problems thrown to us. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, let's talk about some of the ways this manifests in our lives,
乱变得失控、难以管理且适应不良时，问题就出现了。希望我已经把这一点说清楚了：这并不是说我们有什么宏大的、有意识的计划要生活在不断的动荡中，我们喜欢把东西抛向空中看它们落在哪里。这实际上是我们的大脑对奖励的追求。这是我们大脑对刺激的追求。这是我们大脑对能力、自我效能感的追求，去感觉我们能够管理抛给我们的问题。好了，我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，让我们谈谈这在我们的生活中表现出来的几种方式，
why you may end up regretting decisions made in the heat of the moment, and most importantly, how to actually crave peace, stillness, stability over the comfort of urgency. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
为什么你最终可能会对在热血沸腾时做出的决定感到后悔，以及最重要的是，如何真正渴望平静、静止、稳定，而不是紧迫感带来的安慰。所以请继续收听。《2%》。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家进行交流，
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of, of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
以及更多，以看穿主导健康行业的非实用且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Percent。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
第一条规则，永远不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己好像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
警察似乎并不关心，所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
Each episode, we pick you here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一年。剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。然后你完成了那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。黑人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖姆斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将带来超过
decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing. We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kea,
十年来我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时。我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们会看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要，还是你当好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，科尔，
games is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Let's get real about how this plays out in the daily fabric of our lives, especially for us in our 20s. Once you start looking for it, you'll see that chaos isn't just about external events. It's a pattern of thinking and a pattern of behavior that slowly weaves its way into everything. Specifically, the thing that's closest in orbit to us, the thing that often matters more than anything, our relationships, and it manifests in relationship drama. We've all seen it. We've all experienced it. Maybe we've even unconsciously participated
盖姆斯将在我的新播客《艰难学习》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《艰难学习》，立即收听。让我们面对现实吧，看看这如何在我们的日常生活中上演，尤其是对我们这些二十多岁的人来说。一旦你开始寻找它，你就会发现混乱不仅仅是外部事件。它是一种思维模式和行为模式，慢慢地编织进了一切之中。具体来说，与我们轨道最近的事情，往往比什么都重要的事情——我们的关系，它表现为关系中的戏剧性事件。我们都见过。我们都经历过。也许我们甚至无意识地参与了
in it. The breaking up, getting back together, the explosive fights, ignoring someone when you know, it's not healthy, the two and throwing, like the back and forth. For some, A relationship feels boring or stale without a certain level of intensity. This can be fueled by that neurochemical roller coaster, of course, that we just discussed. But for other people, it can also be that calm relationships feel uncomfortable and feel boring. If you are used to unhealthy love, sometimes healthy love can be equally, if not more, challenging because you have to adapt to a new way of communicating, a new way of problem solving, and your love isn't constantly being proven through the resolution of conflict. So you have to
其中。分手、复合、爆发性的争吵、明明知道不健康却忽视某人、两头跑，就像来来回回一样。对某些人来说，没有一定强度的关系会让人觉得无聊或陈旧。当然，这可能会受到我们刚刚讨论过的神经化学过山车的推动。但对其他人来说，也可能是平静的关系让人感到不舒服和无聊。如果你习惯了不健康的爱，有时健康的爱可能会同样甚至更具挑战性，因为你必须适应一种新的沟通方式、一种新的解决问题的方式，而且你的爱并不会不断地通过冲突的解决来证明。所以你必须
create that conflict to feel the same excitement or anxiety that you're used to. Individuals with an insecure attachment style, of course, are more drawn to this, see this happening more often and might unconsciously, unconsciously gravitate towards drama. because it mirrors familiar patterns of attention and connection from earlier life, from your childhood, even if those patterns, you know they are unhealthy. There's another phenomenon attached to this, something that I actually talked about in my book quite a lot. It's called repetition compulsion. Repetition compulsion is a psychological pattern whereby we unconsciously recreate familiar emotional
制造这种冲突，以感受到你习惯的兴奋或焦虑。有不安全依恋风格的个人，当然更容易被这一点吸引，看到这种情况更频繁地发生，并且可能会无意识地、不知不觉地倾向于戏剧性。因为它反映了早期生活、童年中熟悉的关注和连接模式，即使这些模式，你知道它们是不健康的。这背后还有另一种现象，我实际上在我的书中谈论了很多。这叫做重复强迫。重复强迫是一种心理模式，我们通过它无意识地重现我们过去熟悉的感情
experiences from our past, often ones that are chaotic or painful, in an attempt to gain control or resolution, in an attempt to gain mastery, to break the internal cycle. In relationships, of course, this looks like gravitating towards partners who bring up drama, who bring up instability, not because we want to suffer, but because it mirrors a very comfortable emotional landscape. And we say to ourselves, if I can make it out this time, if I can fix this, If I can bring this under my control, if we can make it work, well, then that means that in all these other situations it wasn't my fault. In all these other situations, it wasn't me. It can be this unconscious effort to get it right this time to finally receive the love, validation, stability that we were denied before.
体验，通常是那些混乱或痛苦的体验，试图获得控制或解决，试图获得掌控，以打破内在的循环。当然，在关系中，这表现为被那些带来戏剧性、带来不稳定感的伴侣所吸引，不是因为我们想要受苦，而是因为它反映了一个非常舒适的情感景观。我们对自己说：“如果这次我能熬过去，如果我能解决这个问题，如果我能把它控制住，如果我们能让它运转起来，那么这就意味着在所有其他情况下，这不是我的错。在所有其他情况下，不是我。”这可能是一种无意识的努力，为了这次把它做好，最终得到我们以前被剥夺的爱、肯定、稳定。
The irony, of course, being that instead of healing, we end up stuck in cycles that actually repeat and deep in the original wound. So we pick fights, we go hot and cold, we even think about doing things like flirting with someone else or cheating on our partner. It's a way to feel seen. It's a way to get attention because attention feels like love. It's a way to what we think is build intimacy through conflict because we think that intimacy is born from volatility. This really connects to this very interesting concept called the drama triangle.
当然，讽刺的是，我们没有得到治愈，反而陷入了那些实际上会重复并加深最初伤口的循环中。所以我们挑起争端，忽冷忽热，我们甚至考虑做一些事情，比如和别人调情或者对伴侣不忠。这是一种被看到的方式。这是一种获得关注的方式，因为关注感觉就像爱。这是一种我们认为通过冲突建立亲密关系的方式，因为我们认为亲密关系诞生于波动性。这确实与一个非常有趣的概念联系在一起，叫做戏剧三角。
It's a concept from something called transactional analysis, which is a psychological model essentially developed to describe destructive relationship patterns. And how it goes is that the triangle outlines three roles, three roles that people unconsciously adopt in conflict. The victim, who feels powerless and seeks rescue, the rescuer who tries to fix others and fix their problems, and the persecutor who criticizes or controls to feel superior. These roles are fluid and people often shift between them within the same interaction. A chaos addict, though, might constantly find themselves in one of these roles, perpetuating drama.
这是一个源自“相互交易分析”（transactional analysis）的概念，这是一种心理学模型，本质上是为了描述破坏性的关系模式而开发的。它是这样的：三角勾勒出三种角色，人在冲突中无意识地扮演的三种角色。受害者，感到无能为力并寻求拯救；拯救者，试图修复他人并解决他们的问题；以及迫害者，为了表现得高人一等而进行批评或控制。这些角色是流动的，人们经常在同一次互动中在它们之间转换。然而，对混乱上瘾的人可能会发现自己不断陷入这些角色之一，从而使戏剧性永存。
The average person hopefully isn't in the triangle at all. But if you're addicted to chaos, you may find yourself creating situations where you need to be rescued. You may find yourself in situations where you are allowed to rescue someone else, where you get to be the problem solver. You may find yourself stirring the problem. hot. It is a way of being constantly engaged, constantly relevant, even if the engagement comes from negative interactions. There is, of course, a cost to this. Conflict resolution might create a big dopamine hit. It might make you feel like you've won and you've pushed
希望普通人根本不在这个三角里。但如果你对混乱上瘾，你可能会发现自己正在制造需要被拯救的情况。你可能会发现自己处于允许你拯救别人的情况中，在那里你可以成为问题解决者。你可能会发现自己正在挑起问题。热。这是一种不断投入、不断具有相关性的方式，即使这种投入来自消极的互动。当然，这是有代价的。冲突解决可能会产生强烈的多巴胺冲击。它可能会让你觉得自己赢了，并且你已经推进了
through some issue, but perpetual drama will erode trust in intimacy, 100% of the time. Partners and friends, they love you, they care about you, they also hopefully care about themselves and may get tired of that emotional roller coaster. They might also feel like they're being used as, I guess, props in your personal drama. They're exhausted. They're in a constant state of crisis themselves. Research on relationship dynamics consistently shows that stable, secure relationships, they thrive on predictability, they thrive on emotional safety, not constant upheaval. And genuine connection really does require that we are calm and regulated and that we can co-regulatory. yearly together. So if there's a constant urge to find chaos and to find drama, that's not
通过一些问题，但永无止境的戏剧性将100%地侵蚀对亲密关系的信任。伴侣和朋友，他们爱你，他们关心你，他们也希望关心自己，并且可能会对那种情感过山车感到厌倦。他们也可能会觉得自己被用作——我猜是——你个人戏剧中的道具。他们筋疲力尽。他们自己就处于持续的危机状态中。关于关系动态的研究一致表明，稳定、安全的关系依靠可预测性繁荣，它们依靠情感安全繁荣，而不是不断的动荡。真正的联系确实要求我们平静、受调节，并且能够共同调节。
going to necessarily compute or fit. That's the consequence for relationships. An addiction to chaos will also obviously impact things like our career. This is massive for our 20s. We are often juggling multiple roles, immense pressure, a glorified need to seem busy. How many of us secretly thrive in that environment where there is a last minute deadline? You procrastinate, you let the pressure build, maybe because of perfectionism, then you pull out an all-nighter and you do something brilliant. This is called an urgency addiction. If you find that you can only really get stuff done at the last minute or under a crunch, it may be because you have become reliant on this adrenaline rush. You've become reliant on stress hormones to motivate you.
每年都在一起。因此，如果有一种不断寻找混乱和戏剧性的冲动，那将不一定会计算在内或合适。这就是关系的后果。对混乱的上瘾显然也会影响我们的事业等事情。这对于我们的二十多岁来说是巨大的。我们经常 juggling 多个角色，承受着巨大的压力，以及一种被美化了的、需要显得忙碌的需求。我们中有多少人秘密地在那种有最后一刻截止日期的环境中茁壮成长？你拖延，你让压力积聚，也许是因为完美主义，然后你熬夜通宵，做出了不起的事情。这被称为紧迫感上瘾。如果你发现你只有在最后一刻或在压力下才能真正把事情做好，那可能是因为你已经依赖上了这种肾上腺素的刺激。你已经依赖应激激素来激励你。
It does actually lead to a false sense of productivity because you feel busy. and you feel rushed and you feel exhilarated, even though you're not actually being necessarily efficient or productive. You're not strategically moving forward, but you are fueled by the thrill. This is a classic example of procrastination cycles being reinforced by the relief of completion, even if the overall process is inefficient and stressful. Research by psychologists who are studying chronic procrastination consistently shows that the short-term relief can overshadow the long-term costs.
这实际上会导致一种虚假的生产力感，因为你觉得自己很忙。你觉得自己很赶时间，你觉得自己很兴奋，尽管你实际上并不一定很高效或富有成效。你没有战略性地前进，但你是靠这种刺激推动的。这是拖延循环被完成的慰藉所强化的一个经典例子，即使整个过程是低效且充满压力的。研究慢性拖延症的心理学家的研究一致表明，短期缓解会掩盖长期成本。
And let's be real in a world that is praising hustle culture and praising the grind. It is easy to mistake exhaustion for effort and constant, very high level urgency and activity for actual progression. But what are you actually doing to your body? Business is such a status symbol. You're always over-scheduling. You never have downtime. You're jumping from one project to the next.
让我们面对现实吧，在一个崇尚奋斗文化和推崇内卷的世界里。很容易把筋疲力尽误认为是努力，把持续的、非常高水平的紧迫感和活动误认为是实际的进展。但你到底对自己的身体做了什么？大忙特忙是一个地位象征。你总是把日程排得满满的。你从来没有停机时间。你从一个项目跳到另一个项目。
And so you may conflate being overwhelmed with being important, with being valuable. with being interesting. It's like a badge of honour. And I've done it. I've done it so many times. I was so guilty of this in university. People would want to hang out and I'd be like, oh no, I'm so busy.
因此，你可能会把不知所措与重要、有价值混为一谈。与有趣混为一谈。这就像一枚荣誉勋章。我也做过。我做过好多次了。我在大学里对此感到非常内疚。人们想一起出去玩，而我会说，哦，不，我很忙。
I'm so busy. Like I've never been busier. I've just constantly got all these things on my plate. And it was this weird thing where eventually I had to ask myself, what do I have to prove? What do I have to prove to these people by allowing them to assume that I am, you know, I don't know, by allowing them to assume that I've constantly got things on, by letting them assume or believe that I am the busiest person in any room,
我很忙。就像我从来没有这么忙过一样。我盘子里总是堆满了这些事情。这是一个奇怪的事情，最后我不得不问自己，我必须证明什么？通过让这些人假设我是，我不知道，通过让他们假设我总是很忙，通过让他们假设或相信我是任何房间里最忙的人，我试图向他们证明什么？
what am I trying to prove? I'm trying to prove that I'm important. I'm trying to prove that I can work hard. That's really what this is. The most obvious cost of this all is, of course, burnout. Constantly operating in a high stress, high adrenaline mode is unsustainable. Your body is designed for short bursts of stress. Not a stress marathon. Chronic stress of this kind will elevate cortisol levels that will create sleep
我试图证明我很重要。我试图证明我能努力工作。这才是真正的原因。这一切最明显的代价当然是倦怠。不断地在高压力、高肾上腺素模式下运转是不可持续的。你的身体是为了承受短时间的压力而设计的。不是压力马拉松。这种慢性压力会提高皮质醇水平，从而导致睡眠问题、免疫系统减弱，你会更容易生病、消化问题、焦虑加剧，甚至增加患抑郁症的风险。你总是精疲力竭，你总是易怒，你总是感到脱节。即使你认为自己没事，即使你认为自己还没有真正受够，你不配筋疲力尽，你的身体才不在乎你觉得自己是否配得上筋疲力尽。如果你精疲力竭了，你就是精疲力竭了。
problems, a weakened immune system, you will get sick more easily, digestive issues, increased anxiety, even an increased risk of depression. You feel perpetually exhausted, you feel irritable, you feel disconnected. Even if you think you're okay, even if you think you haven't really had enough, you don't deserve to be burnt out, your body doesn't care if you feel like you deserve to be burnt out. If you're burnt out, you're burnt out. And you're going to feel terrible. There's no ignoring that. Your body will adapt for as long as possible and then it will collapse.
而且你会感觉很糟糕。这是无法忽视的。你的身体会尽可能地适应，然后它就会崩溃。
And as soon as you feel a little bit better, you might feel the instinct to push again and then you'll collapse. And can you see what kind of toll this takes on you? You're not a machine where we can go out and buy another part. I can't go out and buy a new battery for my body. I can't go out and buy a new system of. of organs that are going to sustain me if I keep putting them under such immense pressure that they collapse. You have to ask yourself, what is your love for chaos costing you in the long run? If you're in your 20s right now, it can feel like you could keep going forever. You can't.
一旦你感觉好一点，你可能会产生再次推动自己的本能，然后你就会崩溃。你能看到这给你带来了什么样的代价吗？你不是一台我们可以出去买另一个零件的机器。我不能出去为我的身体买一块新电池。如果我继续给它们施加如此巨大的压力以至于它们崩溃，我无法出去购买一套新的器官系统来维持我的生命。你必须问问自己，从长远来看，你对混乱的热爱要付出什么代价？如果你现在正处于二十多岁，你可能会觉得你可以永远坚持下去。你不能。
One day, you will feel the toll and you'll look back and be like, why was I so busy? What was that all for? We also have to consider, my lovely listeners, whether it might, this whole thing might actually be a sophisticated form of avoidance and looking away from something deeper. Let's have that conversation for a second. The avoidance of stillness and introspection is massive for people in their 20s. We are often grappling with very big questions. Who am I? What do I want? Am I good enough? What is the meaning of all this? What is my future going to be like? These questions really do require quiet reflection and sometimes sitting with really uncomfortable existential feelings because that's how we figure out what we believe in and that's how we integrate hard thoughts,
总有一天，你会感受到这种代价，然后回过头来想：我为什么那么忙？这一切到底是为了什么？我们还得考虑，我可爱的听众们，整件事可能实际上是一种精致的逃避形式，是对更深层事物的回避。让我们讨论一下这个话题。对于二十多岁的人来说，逃避宁静和内省是巨大的。我们经常纠结于非常大的问题。我是谁？我想要什么？我够好吗？这一切的意义是什么？我的未来会是什么样？这些问题确实需要安静的反思，有时还要面对非常不舒服的存在主义情绪，因为这就是我们弄清楚我们相信什么的方式，这也是我们如何将艰难的思想、
hard things, hard truths into our life. If you're asking big questions like, what is the meaning of all this and you really don't have even a single answer and it's getting louder and louder and you don't know where to start? Chaos provides a brilliant, noisy distraction. Research on avoidance highlights how people often engage in these kinds of excessive harmful behaviours to escape unwanted internal experiences. Even if those behaviors are, of course, ultimately unhelpful, the negative consequence of living in chaos feels less significant than the negative consequence of internal chaos that is probably taking over. Because once we stop spinning and rushing, you might look around and be like, oh my God, look at this big pile of crap that I have to
艰难的事情、艰难的真理融入我们的生活。如果你在问一些重大问题，比如这一切的意义是什么，而你甚至连一个答案都没有，而且声音越来越大，你不知道从哪里开始？混乱提供了一种绝佳的、嘈杂的分心方式。关于逃避的研究突显了人们如何经常参与这些过度有害的行为，以逃避不想要的内心体验。即使这些行为最终当然无济于事，生活在混乱中的负面后果也感觉比可能正在接管的内部混乱的负面后果要小。因为一旦我们停止旋转和奔跑，你可能会环顾四周并说：天哪，看看我必须面对的这一大堆垃圾
deal with. This anxiety, this self-doubt, this loneliness, this unresolved trauma. This is so uncomfortable. What if I just run back into the fire? What if I just find another problem that takes priority? Then I won't have to think about it. Recognizing those deeper roots is the first step towards breaking free. Congratulations if you have done it. You're not a bad person for thriving in chaos. You're not a bad person for the things that you have done previously to avoid hard thoughts. But it is time that we shift away from this deeply ingrained pattern. Because you are meant to be present for life.
应对。这种焦虑，这种自我怀疑，这种孤独，这种未解决的创伤。这太让人难受了。要是我直接跑回火堆里去呢？要是我只是找另一个更优先的问题呢？那样我就不用去想它了。识别这些更深层的根源是摆脱困境的第一步。如果你已经做到了，恭喜你。在混乱中蓬勃发展并不意味着你是个坏人。为了避免艰难的想法而做过某些事，并不意味着你是个坏人。但现在是时候摆脱这种根深蒂固的模式了。因为你注定要活在当下。
You are meant to want to strive towards things. You will realize that life does feel easier at a lower frequency. With that in mind, we are going to take a short break. But when we return, I have five tips, just five tips for you to master chaos in your life and turn your pursuit of irregularity and chaos into the pursuit of a regulated nervous system, internal harmony, inner peace, whatever you want to call it. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
你注定要为某些目标去奋斗。你会意识到，生活在较低频率下确实感觉更轻松。考虑到这一点，我们要稍作休息。但当我们回来时，我有五个建议，仅仅五个建议，帮助你掌控生活中的混乱，将你对不规则和混乱的追求转变为对神经系统调节、内心和谐、内心平静（无论你想怎么称呼它）的追求。请继续关注我们。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
健身，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信植物油本身具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends,
收听《2%》。即I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，得蠢奖。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们，
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《女朋友们》中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我随时都可以谈论可卡因，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始发现其中有一条连贯的线索。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and
和我（基尔·盖恩斯）一起，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中。打开你免费的Our Heart Radio应用，搜索“learn the hard way”并立即收听。我们这里的目标不是在一夜之间突然成为禅宗大师。改变从来都不是这样的。我们的大脑也不是那样运作的。建立一个习惯需要时间，消除一种冲动则需要更长的时间，比如我们对混乱的吸引力，这种吸引力可能已经存在一段时间了。这是一笔值得的投资。我们要谈论的是培养意识，做出一些真正有意识的小选择，并温柔而执着地重塑那些根深蒂固的模式。以下是一些可行的想法，我真的希望你考虑甚至在本周尝试的事情，借鉴我们今天已经讨论过的所有心理学知识。
purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app, search learn the hard way and listen now. Our goal here is not to become a Zen master suddenly overnight. Change never works that way. Our brains don't work that way. It takes time to build a habit, even longer to undo an impulse, like our attraction to chaos that has probably been around for some time. It is a worthwhile investment. What we're going to talk about is cultivating awareness, making some really conscious small choices and just gently, persistently rewiring those ingrained patterns. Here are a few actionable thoughts, things I really want you to consider and maybe even try this week, drawing on all the psychology that we've already talked about today.
首先，我需要你弄清楚你个人的混乱触发点，以及你从中真正得到了什么。你可能会问自己以下问题。我什么时候感觉最充满活力？在平静的时刻还是在危机中？这源于哪里？什么情况或什么人总是会在我的生活中制造戏剧性事件或压力？这种压力真的让我感觉良好吗？当事情顺利时，我是否会感到不舒服？
Firstly, I need you to figure out your personal chaos triggers and what you're actually getting out of it. You might ask yourself the following questions. When do I feel most alive? During calm moments or in a crisis? Where did that come from? What situations or people consistently create drama or stress in my life? Does that stress actually leave me feeling good? Do I ever feel uncomfortable when things are going smoothly?
我在那些时刻做了什么？或者在那些我本该做却没做的时刻做了什么？我在冲突中通常扮演什么角色？我是解决问题的人、受害者还是煽动者？我在这个三角形里处于什么位置？我从混乱中得到了什么回报？是关注、肾上腺素控制、分心？通过保持忙碌、不堪重负或处于危机模式，我逃避了什么情绪？
What do I do in those moments? or don't do in those moments that I should be doing. What role do I usually play in conflict? Am I the fixer, the victim, the instigator? Where do I sit in the triangle? What reward do I get from chaos? Is it attention, adrenaline control, distraction? What emotion do I avoid by staying busy, overwhelmed or in a crisis mode?
如果平静感觉像、感觉安全且有回报，我的生活实际上会是什么样子？我能够避免什么？我需要改变什么才能到达那里？所有这一切都是为了绘制你的特定混乱周期和风格。一旦你这样做了，你就会对你真正正在对抗的东西有一个更清晰的想法。接下来，这可能是最艰难的，特别是如果你天生喜欢高强度，那就是你必须尝试将静止作为一种替代方案。我要挑战你，去忽视不断的噪音、不断的刺激。当你感到不知所措时，不要马上放音乐。
If peace felt like, felt safe and felt rewarding, what would my life actually look like? What would I be able to avoid? What do I need to change to get there? All of this is about mapping your specific chaos cycle and style. And once you do that, you will have a much clearer idea of what you're actually battling against. Next, and this is probably the toughest one, especially if you are wide for intensity, is that you have to try stillness as an alternative. I'm going to challenge you to ignore constant noise, constant stimulation. Don't just immediately put on music when you feel overwhelmed.
做饭时不只是看电视。在有了一个不好的想法后，不要立刻玩手机。不要试图寻找混乱的事情来引起兴趣。只给自己留出微小的时刻，允许自己去承载沉重的负面情绪。当被允许在短暂的时间内体验它们然后继续前行时，坐下来，呼吸。你的大脑会尖叫着要求刺激，你会感到烦躁，你可能会感到焦虑。这只是你的神经系统（习惯了高度戒备状态）对不熟悉的平静做出反应，但请坚持下去，哪怕只有五分钟，因为
Don't just watch TV as you make dinner. Don't just go on your phone immediately after you have a bad thought. Don't try and find things that are chaotic to be interested in. Just give yourself tiny moments where you are allowed to just hold heavy emotion. in your hands almost when you're allowed to just experience them for a tiny pocket and then move on sit breathe your brain is going to scream at you for stimulation you will feel restless you maybe will feel anxious this is just your nervous system which is used to being on high alert reacting to an unfamiliar calm but persist even if it's just for five minutes because
那是在训练你的大脑，这是你心灵的耐力训练。五分钟可能觉得不可能，今天做一分钟，明天两分钟，10分钟，20分钟，你就会开始建立对静止的耐受力。我甚至敢说，你可能会开始发现那些你一直在逃避的深刻见解实际上是有帮助的。你可能真的会喜欢感到平静。这基本上就像试图教导你的内部警报系统：并非每一个安静的时刻都是迫在眉睫的灾难的迹象，实际上，平静、安宁、静止、随和、低频率的生活是极其充实和有趣的。你知道，去图书馆喝杯茶，晚上9点睡觉，其实并没有那么糟糕。实际上非常非常有趣。仍然有空间
that is training your brain it is endurance training for your mind five minutes might feel impossible do one minute today two minutes tomorrow 10 minutes 20 minutes you'll start to build a tolerance for stillness you might even dare i say it start to find that those profound insights that you have been avoiding actually are helpful you might actually like feeling peaceful it's basically like trying to teach your inner alarm system that not every quiet moment is a sign of impending doom and that actually a calm, peaceful, still, easygoing, low frequency life is incredibly fulfilling and fun. You know, going to the library and having a cup of tea and going to bed at 9pm, it's not all that bad. It's actually very, very fun. There's still room
让你去做那些高能量、高频率的事情。但如果你发现自己把它们当作一种分心的方式，你该如何时不时地引入替代方案呢？你如何向自己证明，替代方案其实并没有你想的那么糟糕？如果你也对混乱成瘾，那么你很可能也没有建立最强烈的边界，无论是对他人还是对自己。混乱在界限渗透的地方滋生。所以这的另一个要素是在沙滩上划清界限，并尊重你的“不”。当有人要求你做某事时，在腾出空间或允许他们这样做或将你卷入之前，问问自己：我真的想要这个吗？这真的会让我的的一天、我的周、我的生活变得更好吗？
for you to do like the high energy, high frequency things. But if you're finding that you're using them as a distraction, how can you bring in the alternatives every now and again? How can you provide evidence to yourself that the alternative isn't really as bad as you're thinking that it is? If you feel addicted to chaos as well, chances are that you might not have the strongest boundaries, either with others or with yourself. Chaos thrives where boundaries are permeable. So another element to this is about drawing clear lines in the sand and honouring your know. When someone asks you to do something, before just making space or before just permitting them to do it or getting you involved, ask yourself, do I actually want this? Is this actually going to make my day, my week, my life better?
当你去八卦时，当你去参与戏剧性事件时，当你去挑起争端时，当你去填满你的日程表时，记住，你就是你所消费的东西，包括对话、社交媒体内容、他人的能量。你就是你选择参与的以及你周围的一切。那是你想成为的吗？那是一个健康的能量源吗？如果你经常觉得自己的能量不对劲，如果你经常感到被激怒、烦躁，你在生活中对什么说“yes”才导致了这一切，这对你的日常情绪和自我感产生了多米诺骨牌效应？你在参与什么？你允许什么混乱存在，因为你想和不该交往的人保持朋友关系，因为你无法为自己设定界限，因为你无法背离那些不断剥夺你的人。
When you go to gossip, when you go to engage in drama, when you go to start a fight, when you go to fill up your calendar, remember, you are what you consume, including the conversations, the social media content, the energy of others. You are what you choose to engage in and what is around you. Is that what you want to be? Is that a healthy energy source? If you constantly feel like your energy is off, if you constantly feel irritated, agitated, what are you saying yes to in life that is creating this, that is having a domino effect on your everyday mood and sense of self? What are you engaging in? What chaos are you allowing because you want to stay friends with people you shouldn't because you can't set boundaries with yourself because you can't turn away from what is taking from you.
Think of boundaries as your personal firewall against the constant influx of external chaos. They're not walls to push people away. They're basically like property lines that protect your precious energy, your time, your mental peace. It's a proactive step. Really getting to know what you do and don't enjoy and why you feel called to do the things you don't enjoy is incredibly important because you're sending a message to yourself that says,
把边界想象成你对抗源源不断外部混乱的个人防火墙。它们不是把人推开的墙，基本上就像是保护你宝贵精力、时间和精神平静的产权线。这是一个主动的步骤。真正去了解你喜欢和不喜欢什么，以及为什么你觉得有必要去做那些你并不喜欢的事情，这极其重要，因为你是在向自己传达一个信息，那就是：
My piece is my priority, even if sometimes peaceful, feels boring. As we've spoken about, a huge part of why chaos is so addictive as the amazing feeling, we get after the chaotic or stressful period is over. So we also need to create new pathways for dopamine hits, from proactive, preventative wins instead of waiting for a fire to put out to try and anticipate and address potential problems and feel relief then. So we're going to be breaking down our task into small and manageable steps. We're going to be celebrating each small completion. We are going to be planning our weeks. We are going to be feeling a sense of pride when we meal prep. When we do
我的平静是我的首要任务，即使有时平静会让人觉得无聊。正如我们所讨论的，混乱之所以如此令人上瘾，很大一部分原因在于我们在混乱或压力时期过去后获得的奇妙感觉。因此，我们需要为多巴胺的刺激开辟新的途径，从主动、预防性的胜利开始，而不是等着去扑灭大火、试图预测和解决潜在问题，然后在那个时候才感到解脱。所以我们要把任务分解成小而 manageable（可管理的）步骤。我们要庆祝每一个小任务的完成。我们要规划每周的日程。当我们在准备饭菜时，当我们做
things that make our life easier when you call yourself out, when you schedule your downtime first, then fill in the tasks. This shifts you from being a reactive, chaos-driven individual to a proactive, intentional one. It also allows us to tap into delayed gratification, which is probably the most useful concept in this episode. It's also probably something that you are missing. When we're chasing urgency, we often live in a short-term gratification loop. There is an issue, resolution is delayed till the last moment, meaning we get a. instant gratification.
那些让生活更轻松的事情时，当我们自我反思、当你先把休息时间排好再填满其他任务时，这会让你从一个被动的、受混乱驱使的人转变成一个主动的、有意识的人。它还让我们能够利用延迟满足，这可能是本集最有用的概念。这也可能是你所缺乏的东西。当我们追逐紧迫感时，我们往往生活在短期满足的循环中。出现问题，解决方案被推迟到最后一刻，这意味着我们得到了即时满足。
But turning your sights to something that will take you longer, like an assignment or a project that you start early and work on slowly, or like rewiring your communication approach to foster a healthy relationship gives you a stronger, more powerful sense of accomplishment after the fact than if you are just tapping into these short wins. It's so, so, so much more rewarding. It's like choosing the healthy option over the junk food. Instant gratification, junk food, not always. that bad, but not going to make you feel great if you consume it all the time. Long-term gratification
但是，把目光投向需要更长时间的事情，比如你早早开始并慢慢完成的一项作业或项目，或者像重塑沟通方式以培养健康关系那样，事后会带给你一种更强烈、更有力量的成就感，这远比你只追求这些短暂的胜利要好得多。这要值得、值得、值得太多了。就像在垃圾食品和健康选择之间做出选择一样。即时满足就像垃圾食品，不一定总是那么糟糕，但如果你一直吃，绝对不会让你感觉很好。长期满足
is something that nourishes you. It's more rewarding because it taps into intrinsic satisfaction rather than just a dopamine hit. When you engage in something over time, whether it is building a healthy relationship or healing a pattern or showing up consistently for a project, the payoff isn't just the outcome, it's the identity shift that happened along the way, because you start to see yourself as someone who is capable, intentional, grounded. That builds self-trust. You are not just good in a crisis. You are good all the time.
是滋养你的东西。它更有价值，因为它利用的是内在的满足感，而不仅仅是多巴胺的刺激。当你随着时间推移投入到某件事中时，无论是建立健康的关系、治愈一种模式，还是为一个项目持续付出，回报不仅仅是结果，而是沿途发生的身分转变，因为你开始将自己视为一个有能力、有意识、脚踏实地的人。这建立起自我信任。你不单单擅长应对危机。你随时随地都很优秀。
Finally, something that really occurred to me just then and when talking about this and even when I was writing about it is that chaos is everywhere. Life will never be short of chaotic, stressful, pressurized moments. Your life can change at any moment. You don't need to be looking out for it or creating it yourself. It will find you, I promise. It will find you in changing circumstances and unexpected challenges in just the unpredictable nature of being alive.
最后，刚才在谈论这个甚至在写它的时候突然让我意识到的是，混乱无处不在。生活永远不会缺少混乱、压力和充满压力的时刻。你的生活随时可能改变。你不需要去寻找它，也不需要自己制造它。我向你保证，它会找到你的。它会在不断变化的环境中、在意外的挑战中、在活着本身无法预测的本质中找到你。
The external world will always present you with a dose of inevitable turmoil. You don't need to worry about life not being exciting. Trust me, you don't need to create the exciting moments. And if that's really what's going on, if you're exploding your life because you're bored, crashing out isn't going to solve a deeper internal dissatisfaction. You need to be having more planned novel experiences, planning things that are intentionally fun, getting out of your suburb or your town, challenging yourself instead of waiting to blow up your life every three months when you feel unsettled.
外部世界总是会给你带来一剂不可避免的骚乱。你不需要担心生活不够精彩。相信我，你不需要去创造那些精彩的时刻。如果这真的是现实情况，如果你因为无聊而把生活搞得天翻地覆，那么崩溃并不能解决更深层次的内在不满足感。你需要有更多计划中的新奇体验，去规划那些刻意有趣的活动，离开你的郊区或小镇，去挑战自己，而不是每三个月当你感到心神不定时就等着把生活炸毁。
What we're really changing here is the reliance on dopamine from the resolution of an avoidable crisis to a desire for a deeper, soulful state of enjoyment, long-term reward. a calm, emotional environment that's going to mean that when exciting things happen, we can appreciate them rather than feeling like they are going to destroy our sense of self and just set us in a tizzy. It's hard work. It's worth it. So as we wrap up today, I want to leave you with this thought. The chaos in your life, the rush, the constant doing, it might feel like living, but sometimes true living is found in stillness. It is found in intentional moments. in the quiet progress in just a sense of peace, the more mature you get, the more you will realize
我们在这里真正要改变的是，把对“摆脱可避免危机”所带来的多巴胺的依赖，转变为对更深层、更有灵魂的享受状态和长期回报的渴望。一个平静的情感环境意味着，当令人兴奋的事情发生时，我们能够去欣赏它们，而不是觉得它们会摧毁我们的自我意识并让我们陷入狂乱。这很难，但很值得。所以在今天节目尾声，我想留给大家这样一个想法：你生活中的混乱、匆忙、不停地做事，可能感觉像是在活着，但有时真正的活着是在宁静中找到的。它存在于有意识的时刻中，存在于安静的进步和纯粹的平静感中。你越成熟，你就会越发意识到
how desirable that is. Your 20s are a time of immense building and immense excitement. There's always going to be some fire to put out. Don't create more fires for yourself. The pursuit of peace, if you start it now, will create such a better long-term mental state and environment for you so that you're not 30, 40 doing the same things. I really hope that you did enjoy this episode. I hope you know that I'm coming from a place of acceptance. I was once this person, I probably still am. And also just an understanding that if you love chaos,
这是多么令人向往。你的20岁是大量建设和极度兴奋的时期。总会有这样或那样的火灾需要扑灭。不要给自己制造更多火灾。对平静的追求，如果你现在就开始，会为你创造一个好得多的长期精神状态和环境，这样当你30岁、40岁时就不会还在做同样的事情。我真心希望你喜欢这一期节目。我希望你知道我是带着接纳的态度来谈这些的。我曾经也是这样的人，现在可能还是。同时也请理解，如果你热爱混乱、
if you love drama, excitement, sometimes that's just how you're wired. That doesn't always mean that it's an excuse. And it doesn't always mean that you can't do anything about it. Hopefully these tips have inspired you to just take small little steps. I'm not saying you need to. submit yourself to a regular, routine life. From now until you die, I'm just saying, leave space for stillness. Hopefully these tips, and just this conversation has encouraged you
热爱戏剧性、兴奋感，有时这只是你的天性使然。但这并不总是一个借口。并不意味着你对此无能为力。希望这些建议能启发你迈出小小的一步。我并不是说你必须让自己过上循规蹈矩、一成不变的生活，从现在直到你死去，我只是说，为宁静留出空间。希望这些建议和这段对话能鼓励你
to see what the alternative might be. Thank you so much for listening if you have made it this far. Thank you for being such a solid listener. Leave a little pastor emoji down below if you have made it this far. Just for whatever reason, leave one down below so I know that you have made it to the end of the episode and thank you for sticking around. Make sure you are following me. on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and that you are also following us on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening. Leave a five-star review, share this episode with a friend,
去看看另一种可能的生活方式是什么样的。如果你听到了这里，非常感谢你的收听。谢谢你成为这么棒的听众。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留下一个牧师的表情符号。无论出于什么原因，在下面留一个吧，让我知道你已经听到了节目的最后，谢谢你的陪伴。确保你在 Instagram 上关注我：@That Psychology Podcast，并且在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你收听节目的任何地方关注我们。留下五星好评，把这集分享给朋友，
maybe even share it on Instagram. If you want it to reach other people or you think that other people in their 20s or beyond would get something out of it, make sure as well that you listen to my new podcast mantra. It will be linked in the episode description. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Embrace, peace and stillness, please.
甚至可以在 Instagram 上分享它。如果你想让更多人听到它，或者你认为身边的20多岁年轻人或其他什么人能从中获得启发，请确保收听我的新播客《Mantra》（咒语）。它会链接在节目简介中。下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。请拥抱平静与宁静。
we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧不拔的精神、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the, iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at It podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中。1979年对我来说是一个重要的时刻。对大卫来说84年也很重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不好惹。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，.</span
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。艾伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App 上收听《Love Trapped》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。